so obviously apologies um can't be there
in person it would have been great to
have done um
but yeah such as life at the moment um
but i appreciate your your uh
your dedication in making all the way
there um i appreciate it as well that i
understand there's been some extra um
extra restrictions in the last 24 hours
or 48 hours so for those of you i think
that won some raffle tickets or
something i appreciate that you've
chosen to come to this talk as well so
um yeah thanks a lot
so um
yeah i'm gonna probably talk for about
20 minutes maybe maybe a bit more
there'll be some demos as well um
obviously there's a slido um
question and answer area where you can
obviously post questions to
um and i think at the end as well if
you've got it at the end then then
obviously um the the support team
ndc will obviously ask me as well
um feel free to ask questions throughout
the presentation there's no need to wait
until the very end i'd much rather it be
sort of a q a
throughout than anything else really
so um yeah so without um further ado
let's get started then so safe stack um
i assume that you're all in the right
room uh for this then this is about f
sharp and web programming
so um let's get started um so a bit
about me um so my name's isaac abraham
um
i've been a shop dev since the early
days of dotnet um dot at 1.0 so
everything i tell you today
try to think of it as if you guys are
c-sharp developers um think of it as um
i'm also one of you guys that happens to
also write code in f sharp as well um as
i can see there's a few of you actually
could just get right
brief your handwritings who here is
actually doing anything in fsharp today
in a
regular basis
okay
that one right in the corner there that
i can see excellent and the rest of you
i assume i'm hand raised if you're like
dot-net developers c-sharp maybe blazer
type script stuff like this
yeah okay
anyone else who's not a dot-net
developer
okay i'm assuming then maybe javascript
maybe
java stuff like this scala maybe python
whatever but to be fair this isn't going
to be focusing on.net developers so um
yeah
you guys will still get something out of
this i'm sure
um i've been using fsharp for yeah about
five six years now um on a regular basis
um
very briefly the the rationale behind
that um
my journey as a crop developer sort of
got to the end of the road i would say
about about five six years ago where i
was using a lot of practices like tdd
and um
[Music]
solid and the sorts of stuff that many
developers go through their journey and
i i couldn't find a way to
sort of improve how i was doing stuff i
felt there was something missing um i
happened to come across f sharp at the
time and it really resonated with me
i didn't have to give up all the things
about.net that i knew
but i was able to write code more
productively and more succinctly and
just basically get stuff done
more effectively than i could before
i don't want to say that if you're using
if you're not using f sharp today you're
doing it wrong
it's more important about what's right
for you guys and what's right for each
of us for me fsharp's been a great fit
i've been able to write productive apps
build a company
um all around f sharp
um so yeah on that subject so i'm the
founder of compositional i.t
so we are basically in fsharp and azure
consultancy we do training coaching
consultancy and outsource development um
basically all of our team we're six or
seven strong now um we all just do f
sharp day in doubt we're writing web
apps um data driven applications etls
line of business apps all the sorts of
things that you would normally write in
any other language um
someone asked me um recently
is it really possible how do you build a
business in f sharp and it's definitely
possible if um and i would say it's
advisable because it's been pretty
pretty fun and um and pretty um
enjoyable i would say in the last few
years
um
so i've been working with various other
people on safe stack since about 2018 so
you know safe stack is not a new thing
as such it's a few years old now um
and yeah it's got to this point where
it's really become a very nice story a
lot of things have come together things
like dot net core dot net client things
like this that have really um
really worked nicely with with how safe
and f sharp tends to work so what is a
safe stack so
when we first launched it there was a
very very long um description of what it
is but we simplified it when we launched
safe too um about a year or so ago and
we just said it's the best way to write
functional first web applications
um
i would now say to be honest from my
perspective it's simply the best way to
write web apps
that's for me obviously i can't um
comment for everyone but we find it
really productive um we're writing apps
for enterprises as well as startups
and with a lot of the coaching and the
training we do we find people that
haven't got much web experience at all
that are able to be productive very very
quickly
which is also a real benefit we find
so um that's kind of what it is really
but but
before i sort of go further with the
demos and stuff i want to do a quick
demo of a real light that's running now
um we'll talk a bit about that and then
i'll come back and do the slides but the
aim here is really just to to give you
something that shows you immediately
that this is not just smoke and mirrors
there's a real um there's a real thing
behind it
so i'm going to jump over here so this
is um
a real app that you can see is actually
hosted in this year
called safe search
so we we update this app on a regular
basis as we sort of upgrade safe and
stuff
what it is is an app that allows you to
search for property sales in great
britain it's not actually the uk
but um yeah
and
we basically download prices every two
or three months from the uk government
who publish um these these transactions
and we put it into what you would
probably consider pretty standard stuff
so this is a web app being hosted on the
azure app service standard app service
um so if i jump over here you can see
i've got standard app service
everything's working as normal it's
just.net 5.
um
and i've got a search index which is
holding a million transactions a million
documents
so straight away you know this is backed
by normal um azure platform services
nothing magic there in terms of like the
ux so i can start typing in and get find
as you type sort of stuff so i'm going
to search for let's say tottenham
i'm going to search
bigger did you say
yep absolutely
hands up is that okay
yep good
so um so yeah we get some results here
i've got some faceted search on the left
we've got a grid here in the middle
where i've got some search results i can
do things like sorting i can do
filtering i can drag and drop columns
around
if i click view then i get a pop-up with
a map so i'm integrating with them
pigeon maps and open street maps the
same sort of stuff that you might expect
in a normal web app that wasn't written
in fsharp
um if i scroll across i can click on the
postcode and that's going to do another
search but now it's going to show you
properties
in relation geographically to the first
property that i just clicked on
so this is more like using azure
searches geolocation capabilities and
then i can click on a map that shows me
all of the different properties in order
of how far away from the first one they
were
i can get some crime stats um for the
area
so on and so forth
um everything i'm showing you here is
not really f sharp to be honest
so this is basically using a style
framework called bulmer
the css framework
it's using react
the data grid is a component called ag
grid which is a react and javascript
commercial grid component this is using
restarts which is a react component um
there's nothing actually that is
inherently f sharp about this at all
using standard stuff
um just a few other sort of little
things
that you may have not seen or not seen
so as i'm typing in here
you'll see that um
when i go to for example there you'll
see now it's actually got rid of the
little red no search term supplied
and now it comes back again
i get sort of as i'm typing logic i can
even do things more complicated so if i
start typing in a postcode
only when i actually get to a valid
postcode
is it actually
you know making that button enabled on
the right here
so um what i normally do i stop here in
terms of the demo
i'll jump back to powerpoint um if i can
find it
let's go good reading
and i always ask like how much of that
do you think was actually written in f
sharp and i sort of raise your hands and
obviously you probably can guess what
i'm going to say but how much of that
was in f sharp if it's 25 raise your
hands
okay
okay and the answer is
it's 93 i don't know if you can see that
but it's 93 is f sharp javascript is six
percent other as in html was less than a
percent
what is that javascript
that's a single web file so any of you
that are actually javascript devs today
probably will smile when i tell you that
javascript the webpack file has taken up
six percent of my app because webpack is
is webpack that's what it is it's a
lovely
um
javascript configuration uh framework
and so on but um everything else is f
sharp there's no handwritten javascript
there's um one that that 0.7 is one
tiny shell going to play html file and
basically nothing more
there's no handcrafted javascript
there's no handcrafted html there's no
um
html with kind of intermixed f sharp or
c sharp or anything like that the rest
is all f sharp
so um okay good you'll see what's going
on behind the scenes throughout the next
50 minutes 40 minutes
um what is safe stuff really so it's an
acronym that stands for a number of
different components it's important to
understand that safe stack is not a
framework or a walled garden
it's a set of off-the-shelf components
that we have brought together and
basically pre-configured so that they
talk nicely together in some ways like
the lampstank i guess or mean
it's not a framework like blazer um as
so the f stands for sam
which is a server-side web component
that runs on.net and on asp.net core
we'll show you that and talk about that
in a bit more detail of course
um a stands for azure
so cloud hosting and platform services
like i showed you
um we don't force you to use azure you
can use aws in which case it stays with
with uh with safe
you can use docker and host it on a vm
you can run it on-prem in is whatever
our our recommendation is to use it here
we find it's a pretty good platform for
web applications and services
for dotnet as well
um f stands for fable which is a
framework that allows you to
write f-sharp and still target a browser
with javascript
and lastly e stands for elmish
so if there's any of you that are elm
developers out there
is basically an f-sharp representation
of kind of the elm model
so if you're doing any ui programming in
the web today you may be using patterns
like mvc
and if you're doing wpf or silverlight
in the years gone by you may know things
like mvvm
so the elm pattern um again we'll talk
about that in a bit um is basically
called the mvu pattern
so it stands for model update uh and
we'll talk about that as well um
the idea really for safe was to say
if you want to write web applications in
fsharp
rather than you may be having to use
libraries that weren't designed to take
full advantage of fsharp where you maybe
have to write code in a way that feels
somehow unnatural
we wanted to turn it on its head and say
why not write libraries and frameworks
that
let f sharp developers write how they
want to but still take advantage of all
of the really great platforms that are
out there so it's kind of a win-win
situation that's that's really what
we're targeting the same stack
so why would you want to use it um now i
said what it is um one it's very very
productive
um if you're doing javascript today um
and if you're doing f sharp you probably
won't want to be doing javascript even
if you're
a c-sharp devil anyone coming from a
static
type system language a statically typed
language going to javascript may be
quite difficult
because the way you write code is
relying on the compiler to help you to
stop making mistakes and so on
um so for someone like that f sharp is a
really nice fit it's got super strong
type system it's really powerful
you can write all of that but yet you
can still target javascript
you can share types between client and
server so that means
if ever you've written a web application
um you might have ever done something
like i've got a c sharp object that i'm
going to return
from my back end api and on my front end
i'm doing it in javascript let's create
a type type script that matches what the
the c sharp
record or class looks like
some people i know i've actually written
you know t4 templates or code gens that
keep the two in sync
in safe you don't have to do that
because you can write f sharp that
targets both client and server so you
write it once and basically you have a
single file which has your types they
both get emitted to either.net or to um
javascript and there's lots of really
good tooling you may be surprised when i
say that because it's f sharp and f
sharp has got really cool tooling but
actually that's really not the case
particularly because we're building on
top of all of these nice libraries and
frameworks
so we have all of the.net cli we have
javascript tools we have you know react
tooling
visual studio rider vs code all the
stuff that you're probably already used
to
that's very nice in that regard
what we hear consistently from people
that use safe is that it's a really fun
[Music]
pattern and set of libraries to use
particularly those people are not web
developers by trade that they feel that
they are empowered to actually get stuff
done they actually really enjoy the the
cycle
as i said before it's not a framework so
it's pretty flexible we give you an
opinionated starting point you can
change it however you want if you don't
use react you want to use view or
something else don't knock yourself out
there's no restriction on what
javascript libraries you can use you can
use new get packages because f sharp
just runs on.net so on the back end you
don't have to give up any of the
packages that you currently use
um and it's a safe bet i'm not trying to
be smart and have some you know some pun
there by a safe bet i mean it's running
on.net it's running on javascript it's
running on react these are big platforms
mature platforms with mature ecosystems
you're not going to to be in a position
where you're suddenly you know that the
rug is pulled from under you um
we often get asked about commercial
support obviously those platforms
themselves have no doubt consultants
that can help you from the same point of
view we obviously are dedicated to safe
so we've got a team of developers we're
running training courses twice a month
we do coaching um we do support packages
so there's an option there as well
so just to reiterate and make clear here
what we want to do with safe is look at
asp.net core on the back end
javascript
on the front end
but but use f sharp for both of them so
instead of maybe c sharp javascript c
sharp type script we say f sharp both
f sharp itself
when i say simple you may
if you've never used f sharp you may
have heard it's quite a complex language
um
the the truth is is really very
different it's certainly different from
c-sharp or from java
um it's not complicated um i would even
argue particularly with c-sharp 10 and
the rate of change in
that that is actually more complicated
now than f sharp there's many many
different ways of doing things in c
sharp nowadays
f shop has quite a a fairly narrow path
of success that it kind of guides you
down towards and you'll find quite a
high degree of overlap in terms of the
way that people write f sharp which
means you can normally look at one
project and look at another there's
usually pretty close overlap in terms of
signs and so on
it's got a very powerful type system
um
probably a bit more powerful than c
sharps it's got one real feature that c
sharp still doesn't have called union
types or some types um and it's pretty
performant obviously it runs on.net
and net core so all the performance
benefits that we see in dotnet that
sharp just gets for free
okay
so what does it really look like in
terms of stack
just visually to see so
at the top you would be writing f sharp
and then depending on whether your
the code you're writing is on the back
end of the front end
back end would basically be using saturn
and giraffe which are two of these
f-sharp kind of apis
and libraries and on the right you'd be
using this elmish library and fable
which is this tool that emits javascript
and then underneath them they'll be
running on top of either asp.net core
so
effectively you're using all of the the
nice features that asp.net core has all
the performance gains all of that buff
saturn and giraffe are just think of
them as extensions giraffe is really
just
a pipeline stage in asp.net core it's
nothing more than that
so you know all the abstractions like
the eye logger and eye configuration and
builder and stuff that that doesn't go
away that's all still there
the di framework's still there
and then ultimately we're compiling down
to.net core or javascript so for to a
safe developer javascript is not a
language it's more of a runtime layer
it's more of an
il if you will you can obviously use it
um and write stuff in it if you really
want to but we tend not to really look
at the javascript as such
by the time it's minified you know
everything is gone anyway
just to um give you a quick code sample
of what i'm talking about um
this is what what a saturn app looks
like um behind the scenes as you can see
we've got this kind of application block
that looks a bit weird but on the right
you can see this code lens is saying
it's an ihost builder so if you've ever
done any asp.net core before you'll know
that type
app is really simple it's just basically
saying no matter what endpoint you hit
no matter what route always give back
the text hello world but as you can see
if i actually do a query there
you'll see that we see servers castral
so this is indeed asp.net core
and this may be a bit small um depending
on oh i can zoom in wonderful so this is
some f sharp so i've created a record
here
um or just a simple class
um
three fields name location in there i've
got a function called greet which takes
in one of these conference records
i'm just going to say welcome to
conference and year then i've created
one of them here
name is ndc location and year and then
i've called this function with that
record and on the right you can see
we emit some javascript
which is just pretty standard export you
know a class
function some consts and then a function
call
there's a website called fable.io where
you can go to and actually try this out
yourself you get the fsharp on one side
you type you hit save you get the
javascript on the other side
a question already so what's the speed
of the fable compiler compared to let's
say the amp compiler i can't um
compare to the arm compiler because i
don't know how fast that is um i would
say if you're coming from
let's say the dot-net compiler fable is
not as fast as like the c-sharp compiler
or the f-sharp compiler to be honest but
um
given the way that we tend to develop
and save stack we're using things like
module replacement
um it tends not to be a real issue
because you have an initial hit of like
the compiler once off
once you've got the app and you're
making changes the only things that get
recompiled are the changes to your f
sharp code so it's very very quick and
that will go
um but unfortunately i can't comment and
i don't want to say something that is
quicker or slower than the um compiler
because i've never used it in any real
um depth
so yeah i already talked about this um
in fact i'll just skip the slide because
i already uh explained it in detail but
in effect you basically have one file
if you want and you basically target
both environments
that's all that's really cool um
i'm going to jump into a demo or a
couple of demos in a minute um and as
i've still got 40 minutes i can do this
in excruciating painful detail which is
great
i just want to talk about this mvu
pattern before i jump into the code
because this will give it a bit of
context um so the mvu pattern is this ui
pattern um like mvc or mv vm as i said
and
the important thing about it is it's a
really good fit for functional
programming where you have things like
immutable data
and expressions
everywhere
and i think even blazer is potentially
getting something similar to mvu or
they're calling it mvu it's kind of nvus
what really happens is you have a model
which is just at its most basic a class
or set of classes and types
so if you had i don't know
order processing management system or
maybe something like amazon you may have
a type that's got things on it like the
basket and what items are going to be
shown on the screen and what's the
search results and who's the user that's
logged in
and this type gets passed into a
function
which is called either the view function
or the render function whatever and that
functions job is simply i've been given
this current state
please render it to the screen that's
its only job it's got one job
it doesn't care about um
state changes or anything like that it's
only job is i've been given this model
give me a view
what happens afterwards is then there
are ui events
that come through button clicks
piped into text box and so on and so
forth and those are then sent into a
function called update
and each of those will be different
messages so that could be item added to
cart card cleared
checkout complete
and the job of the update function is
basically to say given this message
and the previous model the previous
state give me a new state so it might be
previously we had an empty cart
message is add item to cart the new
model is the old model with this extra
item added into the cart
that's it
and that whole flow just continues
forever
there's no mutable state here there's no
kind of model where we're changing
things in the middle the only place you
change the only place you do anything is
in this one function called update
um which gives you back a copy a new
copy of a model and there's a lot of
really nice benefits to this one is that
it simplifies the way that we think
about our state changes
you don't have to think about sort of
uni bi-directional flows everything just
goes one way you get data in you write a
function that gives you some data out
that's pretty much it
and i'll show you that in a minute with
a real world
example um so yeah so demos demos
so i'm gonna do i think three demos um
now that are more code focused so the
first will be just some basic um fable
just showing you a really low level um
web application that's not got any style
sheets no elmish no nothing just showing
you like the the raw f sharp to
javascript process and then i'm going to
show you some asp.net core
using saturn in giraffe and then i'm
going to show you the full safe template
now
so let's try and start this one so i've
got a basic fable application here so
there's no server here this is just a
client-side f-sharp app
and i'm just going to look through this
is this font big enough for those of you
at the back
yes good
thank you
um
so this on the one hand i've got a
source folder
i've got an fs proj which is basically a
cs project except you change it to fs
i've got some nuget packages
targeting.net standard nothing too
special there
got an fs file which i'll show you in a
minute
and i've also got some some package json
so these are javascript packages and a
webpack conflict file
so we're starting to kind of mix and
match the worlds of dotnet and and
javascript i've got some packages like
webpack to be honest you don't really
need that but we've got it here anyway
i'm going to switch to the browser
let's
see if i can go to my phone
so right so i've launched my apple i'm
going to try and put these side by side
let's see if this works
sure thundershow um
so i've got here fable is running you
can click on this button click me
bosh brush wonderful really not not too
much there
what is actually happening behind the
scenes
is we've got a single htmlr file
which really hasn't got too much in it
button
and this bundle.js and that bundle.js
is what rfshop has been compiled into
what is our shop looking like well this
is our app so i'm opening a namespace
called browser.dom
which is an f wrapper around the the
browser dom as the name sounds i've got
a counter here which is a mutable
variable
so in f sharp everything is immutable by
default so to make it mutable like a
normal
variable i've got to put in this extra
keyword
and then i'm doing some raw dom
manipulation really low level stuff
document dot and i get intellisense here
for everything in the dom and it's
properly tanked it's not um objects if
you look here i can see
with get set so it understands the types
of all of these and things in the dom
and i'm doing a query selector to get my
button
and then i'm casting it into an html
button element you know this is pretty
low level stuff the reason why i'm
showing you this though is to illustrate
that there's no kind of framework stuff
here this is just f sharp rendering is
javascript you can do whatever you want
here i've got an on click handler here
in the handler i'm going to increment
count by one and then set the inner text
to you clicked end times that's all it's
doing there's nothing more than that
really
so it's pretty um low level at this
point obviously say because you don't
have to do this kind of stuff but it was
just to show you that you can do this if
you really want
nothing nothing more than that and i'll
actually just make this a bit nicer
actually let's put in string
information
so i'll save that
just so you can also see and while i'm
here just some of the sort of um tooling
that you get in f sharp in in vs code so
we get obviously intellisense i get sort
of hovers
um
i get things like if i make a mistake
here then i'll get underscore squigglies
i'll get inline error messages
um all that sort of stuff so it's it's
not like you're giving up the world and
there's no um
there's no there's nothing um you know
that you're back to like the world of
you know green screen apps we even get
refactorings to correct errors and stuff
which is quite nice
so um that's kind of demo one the idea
there being you can see that this is
just raw f sharp to raw java there's
really not a great deal more and that
we're using standard javascript tools
here if you're already using things like
npm
then this is going to be nothing unusual
to you that we've got things like
package json and webpack config
if you're the sort of developer that is
coming from an asp.net background where
or maybe blazer where you don't want to
learn javascript you want to hide it as
much as possible
you might not like safe because one of
the key ethos of safe is we don't want
to hide the javascript world we don't
want to stop you from doing whatever you
want we give you easy ways to interact
with javascript
but you still need to know what is going
on you still need to you know have
package json and things like that so
we're not gonna um it's it's not a
framework that hides any of that from
you
and we think that's a better way to go
um for several reasons
okay let's stop that wrap
let's make sure that's gone
good right
so next i'm going to show you is a back
end up so this is now the other side of
safe
which is about writing um
back-end applications so i've got an
empty window here i've got nothing on my
sleeve at all i'm going to create an
asp.net poor app with f sharp from
scratch
so i'm going to say.net new console
for those of you that haven't used um
dot net core so
net is the command line tooling for net
nowadays so i'm just going to say create
a new console application
and this is a um
an f-sharp um console app
it's interesting that today we've got in
um
the world of c-sharp 10 you know these
very simple single file console apps and
so on
it's really i'm really happy to see this
sort of stuff because this has been the
ethos of f sharp for a long time now
it's kind of lightweight you know
friction free and very succinct
applications with a minimum of overhead
so you don't need you've never needed a
class with static void main to to create
a console in f sharp
if you're using.net today by the way and
you're using c-sharp you would have to
put in
to you'd have to put in laying f sharp
dashing f
but because i'm using f sharp all the
time i've set an environment variable so
it always does that
so right let's add sutton
to um
no
um so
i've had a new package you can see it's
a standard package there package
reference includes saturn so nothing
there
behind the scenes although i'm not going
to bore you with all the details if i
was to look in this um
assets json file somewhere deep down
you'll see things like asp.net core app
so it's all sitting on top of this core
now i've got my package let's delete
that and just create a weber
so open saturn open giraffe i want to
create an app
which is an application
with a router
that is going to be text hello ndc
and then i want to run my
that's pretty much it
i'm going to say that watch run
and hopefully we will get a working
asp.net core app
so as you can see down here we've got
the usual sort of standard
microsoft um
castrol sort of logging stuff
and indeed if i go to an endpoint
and i'm just going to use the rest
client that's built into a into vs code
or as an extension rather
i get that color in dc
so behind the scenes this is doing all
the work that you would normally do in
the old asp.net of creating the ihost
builder
setting the config setting the
the extensions and all of that stuff
it's just doing that behind the scenes
and but but nothing more
and i'll just talk very briefly for the
next few minutes and give you some
examples of what this is really doing
and how you can sort of expand on it
and it's probably worth doing actually
because how many of you are using or
going to be using the new um minimal api
in asp.net core or are interested in
that so
one maybe two people okay um maybe maybe
this will this will prepare you for when
if and when you do start looking into
that
um
let's just show you some examples of
what i can do so this is saying give me
some text back and i can see the content
type text plain
if i wanted to make this json i can do
something like that
and this is now going to restart the app
because i said watch run
let's just
and now when i hit this
hopefully now there you can see now
application json
so this is kind of a function that says
give me some text and i'm going to give
you back a handler that's going to
return whatever this text is as as jason
and if i wanted to make this a record or
a proper type fsharp's got really nice
support for like anonymous records so i
could do things like message sequence
that
and then let's say um
date equals system dot date time
today
in fact let's let's be really hip and
trendy and use the new date only
from date time
so um just get rid of the second window
for a minute so this pipeline
function is basically just a nicer way
of me
doing
that
so instead of me saying i want to get
from date time this is the value in f
sharp you've got this pipeline
which is just
pipe and then right arrow
and it says take this data and pipe it
into this function
and it lets you write really nice
sort of dsls where you can say given
this pipe it into this pipe it into that
pipe hit into that as a kind of a
set of data transformations
you can almost think of this as kind of
extension methods in c sharp but without
having to explicitly design this
function to be an extension
okay so just wait for that to restart
send that request again
and now you'll see we get a nice json
object
message is hello ndc and the date is
year month day so that's the standard
serialization for
date only
so
that's kind of a high level the sorts of
things you can do let's spend a couple
more minutes and show you a bit more
about how um
you can do something more than just a
basic application that's returning one
thing one thing only because currently
it doesn't matter what route i put in
it will always give me back that object
so how would i do routine in saturn
so i'm going to actually create a proper
object which i'll call my roots
it's going to have this object called a
router
steal this
replace it with my routes
and here i'm going to use this nice
keyword called get so if someone does a
get
to slash test
then i want to give back that data
let's do another one other
than
goodbye in dc
so now if i try and get to this random
route i should get
a 404
not found
because the only two routes that are
valid are these two here
so now test gives me back this one
other will give me back the other one
and you can compose these roots so i
could build multiple router objects and
then plug them together at the very end
so i could say i've got two different
teams working one i'm working on
checkout apis and the other one's
working on auth
i can have two different router objects
and at the very end of my application i
could say take the routers and then plug
them in to give me a kind of uber router
if you will a massive router that can
delegate to each of them which is quite
nice you get this nice composability
there's kind of a lower level way of
doing this
which is what this giraffe library does
so i've not really said the difference
between these two
satin is basically this library that
gives you this nice sort of router
object with get
this application block giraffe is a bit
lower level but it's um
it's it's still worth falling back to
sometimes and it's good to see because
it gives you a kind of um a nice insight
into how
the routing really works
so let's do
that version as well so
here
we're going to say choose
so i'm going to give this a list in
fsharp
this is a list open close you don't have
to say new list or anything you can just
open square brackets put some stuff
inside it close sweat brackets and you
now have a list
so i want to say here
if the route is a get so it's not a post
it's not put but it's a get
then if the actual root was
test
then get back this object and it's going
to paste this down there
let's just replace that
and then i can do another one
and what giraffe is really doing is
saying right
go through any of these roots if this
one mat if this verb matches then does
this root match if it does do this
if it doesn't fall down to the next one
if that doesn't match oh i've got
nothing more this is now not found 4004.
and i can compose these again as much as
i want so i could say
let's make another one or i can say post
route this let's give back text and post
it
doesn't match then i want to delegate
through to my giraffes
so you can think of each of these as
like the same thing really each one of
these
is its own little router which gets
composed into a bigger router which is
then set as this value and that one is
going to be then set in here then you
can just infinitely plug these routes
together to give you your entire routing
engine basically
so it's really really powerful in that
regard and very very nice
and
i'll probably i'll just do one in a
slightly um
more longhand format
just so you can see um how this might
look
and to show you the asp.net part because
currently there's not really much
asp.net
this is just sort of some abstract
f-sharp stuff
so let's make them hollow ndc which is a
function takes in something called next
in something called context
let's just split this up
data is that
so these next and context if you've ever
written an asp.net um filter or pipeline
stage yourself
next is basically this decorator pattern
or
i think of it as decorated but it's
basically a way of saying we've got this
whole chain of elements we want to pull
one after the other when you're done
with your bit call this one next
and this context object
uh let's just give it a tight annotation
here
context
into that context you'll see this is the
full asp.net context
so i can go all the way down i can say
get service i logger if i want you know
all that sort of stuff there's nothing
stopping me doing any of that stuff um
it's it's all there it's not hidden away
um
it's all available for you to do
everything that you do today in asp.net
core
except we don't force you to use all
that stuff if you don't need to if you
want very simple stuff it's really
really lightweight and part of this is
because of that the nature of f sharp
where you can do these kind of nice dsls
without too many operators or
you know brackets and and curly braces
and stuff it's fairly lightweight in
that regard um but if you do want to
then you know we don't stop you doing
that at all and of course you know you
might want the di container or the um
logger or eye configuration that's all
still there
so um that's kind of a whirlwind
overview of saturn and giraffe
um just again to emphasize using these
libraries it's not an either or in terms
of asp.net pool
you can still use the standard i host
builder you can use all of that stuff
but then pick and mix some parts of
these libraries as you see fit
personally i would always recommend if
you are thinking about doing web apps in
fsharp um to use giraffe at a bare
minimum
just because um if you use the standard
web api and so on they forced you down
the road of using classes pretty much
except for like the minimum api now
nothing wrong with classes
but f sharp is more about typically
lightweight functions plugging things
together with small bits of con small
bits of functionality composing them to
make larger things
um which is kind of it's not against the
the that that is not against the c-sharp
ethos
or dotnet in general but this really
brings that to the fore and really
encourages you to write lots of little
functions and do one thing one thing
well and then use this these operators
to kind of plug them together
all right let's stop that one
so we've got still perfect we've got 15
minutes that should just be enough to go
through the last demo
so um
i've shown you kind of these two things
so far client apps and server side but
um i haven't really brought them
together which is really what the
safestack's about
so i'm going to show you just um
i'll just jump to the browser quickly
there we go right good
so um if i go onto the website
yes um thank you stefan yes middlewares
absolutely so it's asp.net middleware
that i'm talking about so giraffe is
just an asp.net middleware that's really
all it is um and indeed if you do things
by hand um
and you don't use saturn to sort of
build that application block up you will
literally go into asp.net core and in
your configuration you'll say add
middleware and there's a giraffe
middleware
what actually is it um given what
everything i've just spoken about um
it's just a nuget package
um that is basically a dotnet template
dot net new template that comes with a
lot of this stuff out of the box for you
so if i um
go back here and i do net new list
you'll see somewhere hidden away
safe
i know it must be here because i created
it not 10 minutes ago let's go back a
folder just in case
there we go
safe snack web app v 3.1
so it's just a um a template you
literally say don't let new safe this is
what you get out of the box so while
we're doing this i'm just going to start
the app because it can take a few
seconds to start up
so we'll leave that there and i'll show
you what that is but while it's doing
its thing
i'm going to just talk what do you get
with a safe app
so out of the box
there's a few folders here like vs code
and vs you can ignore them but what
you'll get is a package.json file
which contains a bunch of dependencies
that we've tested that work well
together things like webpack
sas react and so on and so forth
we also give you a web pack file
which does the sort of the the standard
things that you would expect from a web
app single page web app
so
that's another proxy
minification bundling all of that sort
of stuff is done for you
um you get a dependency chain for the
dot app we're using packet if you don't
know what packet is it's basically an
alternative client for nougat you don't
have to use this if you don't want it
and there's an alternative version of
the template well it's actually it's the
same template but there's a flag you can
pass in which says give me a minimal
safe app and it will give you a bare
bone safe app with with
much less in the way of what's going on
here so you can really go from a low
level and try it out yourself and build
it up yourself as well
um we basically give you like a client
folder with a client app so that fable
app i showed you before the server app
which is the saturn application that i
showed you before and then a shared
project where you can store shared types
and functions that go onto both the
client and onto the server so for
example here i've got a to-do record
which is just a normal f-sharp record
but that will get compiled into
javascript to live on the browser and i
can just access it seamlessly and it
will always also go into the server as a
net assembly as normal.net type
we also give you some tests projects so
we have a server project for tests we
have some client tests so if you want to
test your client application out and so
on
let's just see how um
what's going on there oops would
actually help if i had actually gone
into the correct folder so that's uh
netconf that
not now
so i'm just going to start this
application now and as you can see we're
just using.net run
to actually launch this application so
if you've used um
net before it's exactly the same sort of
tooling
behind the scenes what we're doing is
starting up the javascript app and the
server app as well at the same time so
um we're not highlighting them you know
you can see up here
we're doing npm install and stuff like
this um there's no kind of um yeah
there's nothing hidden
this is where fable is clicking in it's
now compiling our f sharp to javascript
once that's kicked in webpack will then
start its dev server up and set up hot
module replacement and so on and so
forth
so that shouldn't take too much longer
um
let's see if there's anything else worth
showing you before we go much further um
mode modules pretty standard okay good
so there's our server that started up
now running on 8085
and now webpack is kicking in and that's
going to start to transpile our code not
transparent minify our code
into um
and start it on its own devweb server
so
compilation is done now it's bundling
everything together starting the webpack
dev server and then we'll basically have
an endpoint we can go to
right so i'm now going to go to my
browser i'm just going to direct this up
localhost 88.
okay
so
this is what you get out of the box with
like.net new safe you get a to-do app so
you can have a look at what it's doing
um and obviously then play around with
it to your ex to your heart's desire so
what i'm going to do is just do a couple
of small um
changes to the app and show you some of
the tooling and the dev experience for
what it looks like
so i'll
add in a couple of items here so let's
do something like learn
learn f sharp
i'm going to open up the um
the console here apologies if this is a
bit small i'll try and make it bigger
and
looks like that's the best i'm going to
get i'm afraid sorry
but i'm going to refresh this page i'm
going to hit f5
and you'll see that nested amongst all
these things is basically this call here
to get to do's
i can make it bigger there we go and all
i'm getting back here when i'm pulling
this list of to-do's is just standard
javascript and just standard json
nothing magical there just json objects
over a standard restful api
when i add something in so um
love saves
add
then we get
and then add today which is a post
and we're sending through in the payload
a normal object there's a question there
what are you using to get refactoring
and automatically adding of open
statements
so there's a um extension for vs code
called ionite if you want to do f sharp
install ionize you get all of that out
of the box um so that'll give you
refactorings rename refactorings
all the the intellisense all of that
don't do it do f sharp without that it's
you get nothing it's just like using a
text editor then
so yeah ionized is what you want
of course you don't have to use vs code
i'm happy i have to be using vs code
here
you can use visual studio
you can use jetbrains rider you could
use notepad if you really wanted to
rider has really good support for f
sharp slightly different to vs code but
it's pretty good visual studio has very
good support for f sharp slightly
different to vs code as well
there are some pros and cons to all
three of the id's so i'm not going to
say use one over the other
vs code is a decent starting point
it's cross-platform
it's free and it's pretty quick and easy
to get started with
so um i've created my my apps i'm just
going to show you as well
now i've added those items in
some of the other tooling you get so
because we're sitting on top of react
and redux
we can use all the tooling that that
comes with so redux is a library for
like this kind of functional state
management in the browser
and it basically lets me do things like
um time travel so i've got my app here
and i can actually go back in time and i
can actually start to
see what i did
and then go forward again
because everything is is just a function
call with a clear sort of separation of
state if you remember back to the mvu
panel where i said it's just
forward only
loop effectively
that's really what redux is doing for us
it's trapping those states and i can see
this was my model before this is what i
had this is what i've now moved to
so um this is nothing we've built in
safe stack this was part of react redux
so all of those tools you can use you
know javascript debugger that sort of
stuff if you want to debug the
javascript you can do that as well
okay
good we're almost out of time so i'm
just gonna pick up the pace a little bit
so um
i'm just gonna show you one last uh
thing so one of the things we've added
into what we've got in sage stack is
this thing called fable remoting
if anyone had done any silverlight in
the old days and remembered something
called rear services it's basically
similar to that so because we have this
notion of
shared code across client and server
maybe if i open the right file that will
help
um
we can create an api
so these are my methods that my backend
supports get to do's i can do reset all
my to-do's
behind the scenes we are going to create
a proxy on the client for this that will
send messages to the back end which will
handle the serialization and
deserialization for us
so we don't even have to worry about
that
and on the client i'll show you what's
going on here in a minute
i can literally do things like to do's
api dot
and i get add get and reset they just
look like method calls but behind the
scenes it's doing json serialization
http back and forwards and so on so you
don't even have to do that if you don't
want to and if you want to do manual
http json not yourself out but out of
the box you don't even have to do that
you can just give it um f sharp data it
will package it up on both sides you
won't even realize you're going back and
forth if you don't want to
so um what i want to add is a reset
button onto this
so that you can at least see kind of
what the dev flow looks like
so i'm going to move this to the right
you know what's that
and i want to add a reset button in so
remember i said to you we have this
thing called mvu so our model currently
has a to-do list
and an input string
so i'm going to add a new message onto
our list of messages
which i'm going to call reset so
whenever someone hits the reset button
that's the command i want to fire
i immediately get a warning here f
sharp's telling me in my update function
if i move across here incomplete pattern
matches the value reset indicates a case
not covered
so it's telling me already you've not
dealt with this case please deal with it
so i'll add the casing
and all i'm going to do when someone
hits reset i'm going to clear out this
list
so i'll take my current model
and i'll say with to-do list equals
empty list
and there's no other command i want to
do after this
that's my my thing done the last thing
is my view and this is where things may
look a bit weird
this is our
our view function there is no html
or raw react we do it in f sharp and
it's basically a type safe wrapper
around react and in this case around
bulma that someone's done
so if you think of this as kind of
that's where my my children on top of
this node go in html that's really what
this is so we've got some attributes
here
sending the style which has some
children
then i'm setting some children on the
hero
to be this one and that one and so on
but it's really just
a type safe way of doing view code
in some ways it's not so dissimilar to
what the um javascript and to swift have
done
all these colors in i've got a question
as well
all these colors in indent auto complete
narrow messages where do they come from
is that a vs code plugin um there's two
plugins i use for that one is um code i
think it's called uh
indent lint or something like that which
gives you these little indent brackets
and the autocomplete out of the box with
with mvs um we with ionide error
messages they come from the f-sharp
compiler there is an inline error which
is basically so if i do something like
that it shows it there but that's just a
standard vs code extension nothing um
about f sharp
um the database question will come to in
a minute i know we've only got two
minutes left so i'll just quickly run
through this
i'm going to add another button
onto my
screen so i'm going to copy that code
which was this sort of control with a
button i'm going to hit save now because
we've got hot module replacement in it's
already added it i've not stopped and
start the app
so i can now hit reset
change the text to reset and now the
text will change to reset
and then i can change it to is warning
instead of is um primary so the collar
is going to change now to a warning
color
and then i'm going to change the rule to
say only disable if my model dot to-do
list is empty
can't reset if the list isn't empty of
course
and then the last thing is
when someone clicks on it i want to
dispatch my reset message
so that's kind of tying the loop up and
closing the loop
so now i've done that um i should just
be able to hit reset
and there's our list gone
and if i wanted to go to the back end
it's pretty simple i can just add in a
line here say kick off a background
process
to call the server
which is going to be our to-do apis dot
until it sends up reset and now that
will actually reset the um the backend
sorry start
so that's um that's basically tying up
to an existing back-end method that
already existed not the time to actually
show you that one i'm afraid but um yeah
basically what i'm saying so
um with that said i've got probably 30
seconds left i'm just going to jump over
to my slides very very quickly and then
we'll try and answer any questions as
well
so let's just go back here
demos right so it's not vaporware it's
not magic it's f sharp it's net it's
javascript there's no boundaries there's
no walled gardens use whatever js
libraries you want um
safety of f sharp type safety tooling
all of that stuff is there it's really
fun i can only speak from my experience
and those i've dealt with but it's
productive it's flexible we're doing
large large apps four or five put you
know from our point of view four or five
developers working at once all in f
sharp
back and front end um for enterprises
i've already touched on minimal apis
if you like that kind of thing f sharp
is basically been doing that since day
one
um any of the new features in that
you'll get up except for hot module
reload because that is a c sharp only
thing at the moment maybe in the future
that will change
um any of the performance gains in.net
specs any of the new types you get all
of that stuff as well
um
safe stack github io just google safe
stack um it'll be the first link you get
you can type you can um go through the
site i'll show you very briefly um
there's basically docs on there we have
a very large um set of
docks on there
so let's just go to it so we have a
whole set of recipes
let me do that
we have like how to quick start we have
a whole bunch of how do i guides how do
i connect with database how do i do dev
test how do i deploy um they're all
pretty you know
they're reasonably detailed
you can obviously always reach out as
well and ask so we've tried to get up to
people that aren't f sharp experts you
don't need to be to use it
um but the last thing i would say is
yeah ask me anything so um
lovely i think we're just overrunning
but i think if we've got another minute
or so um there was a quick question what
libraries do you prefer for databases
um you can use anything there's nothing
to stop using any library um we prefer
something like dapper
um
entity framework doesn't really work so
well with immutable data um it's geared
up towards having this kind of read data
in
make changes save changes sort of thing
which isn't a great fit for ref sharp um
but something like that works very very
well and there are plenty of nice
wrappers around them as well um but repo
db
also works great um see what works for
you depends on your plan
so yeah i think that's about it um thank
you very much for coming and for your
questions if you've got any questions
now feel free to ask them
otherwise um feel free to reach out to
me either in slack twitter email always
happy to chat to people looking into f
sharp or safe